en 2022 20 países llevaron a cabo
ejecuciones lo que significa un aumento
del 53% en los últimos 12 meses y el
mayor número en 5 años un informe
revelado por amnistía internacional
asegura que las 883 muertes registradas
se produjeron principalmente en Oriente
medio y África del Norte
siempre terminamos con la misma cantidad
de estados que Ejecutan siempre
alrededor de 20 había 20 en 2022 había
18 en 2001 pero siempre son los mismos
que encontramos esencialmente en la
región Mena es decir en medio oriente y
en el norte de África con campeones como
Irán Arabia Saudita y Egipto de hecho en
los países autoritarios hay una
tendencia a usar la pena de muerte como
una herramienta de terror en la
población
las ejecuciones aumentaron junto con el
retorno de los juicios tras la pandemia
del covid 19 en los países de medio
oriente algo que el informe califica de
matanzas sancionadas por el estado
en Irán las cifras aumentaron de 314 en
2021 a 576 en 2022 a raíz de la
represión generalizada en contra de
activistas antigubernamentales
en Arabia Saudita amnistía señaló que
las ejecuciones fueron las más altas
registradas en 30 años con 81 personas
ejecutadas en un día china es el
principal ejecutor del mundo Aunque la
cifra exacta no es Clara amnistía estima
que se encuentra en miles Corea del
Norte y Vietnam también aplican la pena
de muerte pero los datos oficiales
siguen estando fuera de su alcance pero
el informe también muestra que seis
países han abolido la pena de muerte
total o parcialmente Estos son papúa
nueva Guinea kazajistán y cuatro
naciones africanas